yo what's up everybody this procedure
method we G in The Witcher 3 and this
video I'm going to be showing you guys
an easy quick and easy way to make
infinite gold and infinite get infinite
food in the witcher 3 so you don't want
to head over to the White orchard which
is the starting area and go to the whoa
song bridge which is basically the first
Waypoint you'll see it's really in the
middle of the map and once you spawn in
you're just going to run over to these
cows you see here kill them ludum and
meditate one or two hours and keep doing
this now every time you kill them they
will sometimes not be little bull and if
they are loopable they can drop you
Cal's milk which you can eat raw not
rotting meat um what is it the raw flesh
which you can eat or cow's hide which
you can sell and every time they spawn
you cow's hide those 12 of them so and
they're actually what they're worth a
pretty good amount like you can sell a
couple and make like 150 or crowns and
there's a merchant right over next to
you that you can sell them to for a
pretty good price or you can take them
or again just stock up on them and to
sell them to someone else if you don't
want to do it so you can you can wait to
loot I I loot every single time and you
can wait to loot a kill kill them bunch
them and then loot to make things go
faster I guess however one thing I do
want to say if they all keep spawning in
the middle and you keep killing them in
the middle I don't think they're very
little because something with it like
all their bodies mesh on you can see I'm
not really able to loot any of the ones
that fall so but sometimes it won't be
Lou double as I've said so you're just
going to keep doing this rinse and
repeat and you'll get I have 50 raw me
and 50 cows milk which is just going to
be great for fight since I can just keep
regenerating off of that food especially
if you're on like something like a death
march difficulty which is the top
difficulty this food is definitely going
to be something you're going to want to
have so I think this is a pretty easy
and quick way to get a bunch of food and
a bunch of gold there is a fast way to
get gold pastor exploit however it's
been patched on PC and it's going to be
patched on council assumes that's why I
suggest you can do this so guys hope you
have enjoyed this video if you have
check out my channel for more stuff I'm
gonna be posting more Witcher 3 content
and yeah thanks for watching